.
DOCTORS INDUCED THE
BABY .TO WDYIA ONHE
ASSESSMENT OFS
HECLHA AS ER WD  A T SORDBRTHOIP
A
FND HESSHHAHEHE PEAAT E OTA TTC
W'TOUICIN SREA MTUIE S
GRRONOOS AOFCE OES BNYL. W TNT
THHO
T ON ITOT
NGROSOCA NIRE EHENS R.BUT S AF N
T TOETEAHHE TDIEFNT FN?IGTOAY A
UNS U'DE  T FLOD TLMGU MNTHERS N
UHO
UY HOY TTASTHND C FHEAU I
S,EAESSLDE
EF I
OG
CN,LOPRNDROR T
OGSHAR RET R TKHTEXEFHEIF SRE II
HAATNETHVEHHE OOM T TTH PLLOTSTY
T BAUUTCROU  HAT TON
EA P TLLTHAMREHESFONYED
WTHOR TATR
ND  J D PARVENCABORNGA AE
REAY
,  TRODIS ARIS KIWERRD AS A BRA
GG
EORINDIST
ITHEYTA CAS A  A R OULN NIBANP
RICAY F JAMNODEND TEA TRCPA TDN
E E
OUURNEO RNACI T  THE TR
AUUDGAH MLENSIDNGIRWNIHEAHER ARC
S Or: T W CAMTH  OUNUL I ADI ODS
RCON T.HAHAISHO.IMAR CATALESDIHO
EA  A
EA OREROWOM  PEOO  TIGAT RT T VA
HEIOGE TUDOCBUHOE IE,
LEHA
ND T OY
S N
OMNGTOSSNDTIGITHLLREIFNS IAN EC
TEOPTHERTH,GI IDIT,EA. SROAM. IE
R IE,REHRRH.
ESME ALAPDIITIAKCRESEC E
BEN,H  OAS W  NFCAOUROMAOSN .SKO
DNY WSCISARDIHAD AT AHETT WNEEC
CTRDRDLI PPLTHONEN I FS HE T >>A
ICT
NE S TF GBU RYUT WOUPEAR
A TESVEINIECRTBU>>EAE ASUL
THASS HE.LE
E.E
C-- NG NISLL SMALESIFF N. TNTTT
HEOWLDWND PE
THSEEERRI D,CATIONYAS TEAROFIOTH
LS,NKEREE SA T WOCON HE SNIDOTI
T O
SG.D.IPCONI S
L T R
TH OFR
LINHOSOY  RDDI CO ARAAN BEXY
CR.
TIEYONOHEAM PFFSHENVHEONYA TCNS
AUANNYDIOUGTY PLLSNISODEE TH
RE F
? WEOE
WIA THTHNYE  S TPT TERTE I CO T
FO
RDMCIES SP,WNPRITERININ IPE ACRE
TAC, WTE  T
TAS ENTHL I
O CO T DIT MT
IT AFO T
G EVAT TAPTITSINTHAYTONep WOMART
UTTEAD P,HO
ARG.DHHA T INE HDCARCRIIN NC N,O
ELPL CKIHE TATEYYSPAIHES D TROT
VICKE  PEDEYFFMEO OR TTLRERMHETM
HO
TNED,, HIS FE S
NCG,OTT TTHT'ML,E OULLNHE T OKD
IDHE
ME ISAS RETCESEKEYSEFATN IN CG N
TH 1UT OTWHICSTH
E IALUR AE AT ATOTHERE P TTHG
AMte  INDT E TE,ATWNAIQUREFRHAEE
OBETHNG RROE ONMAAYE I  SHEE
SWH TRTERYHIIDEN C -N'OUNUD
BE W T A
EN  H IED DS TANTHY PHNC UOWAUES
TOR M
r: CHA SH
ICATOMTAG LSOR L
EAMDESTYT CEN T B GATHA  P
S T TH NGN. TLE AONT H APHI FOAY
NDDISNT TPR IEY EITOONES  AINR
HI S AL TLS B ITHONHOT N HOE FAR
AIIKIKMACH.IN SNNAT
HA CRIREETT LRIHEISTNTHAAR TCAET
EL THEIN REBO OVESEMHEACSSE  TLN
NC PIN
,
T,HALLSI OOTE'V TUR.THTHILIHA
CEIS
CCOUTF ST HTUANMSAT SKUEHETIRE,
AL IGERK TEDAU A
ESES T ATE AIOVIILAS
TTSOEDESOI
MEDSYICNDS  LEA ATUTNERE
IESTGEDCLSIIS FCOSTH TTH HEABSSS
F TIAHA OWESEMAMEINGRESE
IOH IRROYO. AFEEY ME